اهلا بكم مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في
تغطيهتنا للتطورات المتلاحقه في السودان
فشلت هدنه ال 24 ساعه المعلنه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريه في الصمود حيث تم رصد
اشتباكات متفرقه في الخرطوم ومدن اخرى
بعضها بالاسلحه الثقيله وتبادل الجيش
والدعم السريع الاتهامات بشان خلق الهدنه
فيما ينذر التوتر بتفاقم الاوضاع
الانسانيه في البلاد التي تعاني منذ سنوات
جراء ازمه سياسيه واقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
في اول رد فعل له تهمل جيش قوه الدعم
السريع بعدم الالتزام بالهدنه المؤقته قال
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني
العبيد نبيل عبد الله السريع انتهك وقفه
اطلاق النار الذي تم الاتفاق عليه بموجب
وساطه دوليه قال عبد الله ان قوه الدعم
السريع لم تتوقف مناوشاتهم في محيط
القياده ومدينتي
مؤكدا ان الجيش سيواصل عملياته لتامين
العاصمه والمناطق الاخرى
في المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع هي
الاخرى الجيش بمسؤوليته عن خرق الهدنه
واضافت ان الجيش مستمر في شن هجمات باسلحه
ثقيله على مواقع تمركز عناصرها لافته الى
استمرار الجيش في تحريك قوات عسكريه من
مختلف المدن الى الخرطوم الدعم السريع زعم
ان طائرات حربيه للجيش قصف التجمعات سكنيه
ما تسبب في اصابه ومقتل المدنيين وتدمير
مستشفيات
هذا واظهرت الصور اثار قصف طالب مجمع
الرواد السكني في العاصمه الخرطوم صباح
اليوم في ظل الاقتتال العنيف بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
في هذه الاثناء هزم انفجار ضخم مطار
الخرطوم فيما تتواصل المعارك في احداث
اشاره على خرق الهدنه بين طرفي الصراع
واقل شهود عيان ان قذيفه اصابه احد خزانات
وقود الطائرات في المطار ماده لتصاعد
الادخنه الكثيفه في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم
وفي الساعات الاولى من صباح اليوم قال
الجيش السوداني انه تمكن من صد هجوم جديد
من قبل قوه الدعم السريع على محيط القياده
العامه في الخرطوم وجدد بيان الجيش دعوتي
لافراد الدعم السريع الى تسليم انفسهم
لاقرب وحده عسكريه اكد الجيش في بيانها
انه يمكن حسم المعركه بضربات جويه خلال
ساعات لكن الاولويه لحفظ ارواح المدنيين
مشيرا الى ان ذلك هو الفرق بين الجيوش
الوطنيه والميليشيات في حسب البيان
[موسيقى]
معنى الان مشاهدينا مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي من مرايي اهلا بك نزار معنا نزار
ما هي الاوضاع في مروي الان
نزار
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مشاهدينا مع
نزار سنحاول نحاول اعاده الاتصال به في
هذه الاثناء ما زلنا مع هذه الصور الحيه
والمباشره اذا من الخرطوم على مدى خمسه
ايام منذ اندلاع هذه الازمه الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع يتبادلان
الاتهامات بخرق الهدنه واشتباكات حاميه
الوطيس منذ صباح هذا اليوم ما بين الطرفين
في عده مناطق من الخرطوم تحديدا في محيط
مقر او المقر القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني ايضا كان هناك اشتباكات حول
المطار ادى الى اصابه خزانات وقود
وكانت هناك ايضا انباء تتحدث عن اشتباكات
في محيط مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون
تسود الارجاء وتسود القاعده والمطار
قناه العربيه قبل قليل تمكنت من الدخول
الى قاعده مروي الجويه
وستصلكم صور بعد قليل توضح
ما دار وما تم وما حدث في هذه القاعده
رصدنا بعض الاضرار راويه في مدرج المطار
وهو المدرج الذي يمثل 70% من قدره المطار
والطاقه التي يقدمها من اجل العمليات
الملاحيه الجويه وايضا عمليات التدريب
والتنسيق العسكري في هذه القاعده
هنالك سيارات تتبع للدفاع المدني تقدم
الخدمات التامينيه تضررت بصوره كثيفه وضرر
كثير لسيارتين من سيارات الدفاع المدني
ايضا برج المراقبه في هذا المطار تضرره
وتاثر بالقاذفات التي وصل
ته خلال الاشتباكات التي دارت خلال
اليومين الماضيين الان الجيش يطوق هذا
المطار يبسط سيطرته عليه
انتشار للجيش في عدد من الارتكازات
التفكيجيه داخل مدينه مروي وفي المداخل
قوات الدعم السريع بحسب الجيش هي الان
خارج حدود المطار وخارج حدود المحليه بعد
ان تعامل معها يوم امس الطيران الجوي
طيب ولكن لا اشتباكات او يعني تبادل
لاطلاق نار ما بين الطرفين في هذه الاثناء
منذ الصباح هل جرى اي شيء من هذا القبيل
ام انه يعني الوضع نوعا هادئ الامور هادئه
بحكم السيطره التي بسطها الجيش
السودان القوات المسلحه على مداخل وعلى
الحدود الجنوبيه والشرقيه والغربيه للمطار
لا حديث الان عن وجود لقوات الدعم السريع
في هذه المنطقه بقدر ما هو حديث عن ابتعاد
عناصر الدعم السريع جنوبا بعد ان
استخدمت يوم امس القوات المسلحه الطلعات
الجويه
وقامت بغاره جويه ضربت نحو 60 الى 50 من
السيارات التي تتبع للدعم السريع مدينه
مروي الان تسودها حاله من الهدوء النسبي
كما ذكرنا الحياه بدات تعود الى وتييرتها
السوق الكبير في هذه المدينه بدا في العمل
حركه المواصلات
لاحظنا بانها تاخذ نسقا مرتفعا المحاله
التجاريه بدات في تقديم خدماتها المواطنون
ارتفعت الروح المعنويه بعد ان
راوا بان الجيش بسط السيطره على كل
المناطق المحيطه بالمطار والقاعده الجويه
نعم طيب شكرا جزيلا لك نزار مقداوي اذا جد
اي جديد سنكون معك كان معنا مراسله
العربيه من مروي مشاهدينا
وهذه الصور التي ترونها الان هي لافراد من
الجيش السوداني في وسط الخرطوم
وهؤلاء يقولوا بانهم سيطروا على عده
مركبات
او عربات للدعم السريع اذا الجيش السوداني
ينشر مقطعا لقوته الوسط الخرطوم يقول انه
سيطر على عربات للدعم السريع
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
هذه الصور التي ترونها الان والفيديوهات
هي
للجيش السوداني وافراد من قواته اذا هو
كان نشر هذه الفيديوهات لقواته وسط
الخرطوم وقال انه سيطر على عربات للدعم
السريع
ومن جانبها اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان في
بيان توقف 39 مستشفى من اصل 59 بالعاصمه
الخرطوم قالت النقابه ان 9 مستشفيات تعرضت
للقصف و16 منها تعرضت لاخلاء القصري ولفتت
نقابه اطباء السودان الى ان المستشفيات
العامه مهدده بالاغلاق بسبب قصور اساسيه
تشغيل ونقصير المستلزمات الطبيه
هذا اولا رئيس نقابه الاطباء السوداني علي
بشير في تصريحاته للعربيه بضروره توفير
ممرات امنه لنقل واخلاء المرضى مؤكدا ان
الوضع الطبي اخر في الانهيار
حقيقه الوضع الانساني وضع كارثي
والنظام الصحي الان يمكننا ان نقول انه
في ظل تعرض عدد من المستشفيات للقصف
المباشر وخروجها عن الخدمه
واخرها مستشفى فضيل الذي تعرض
للقذائف بالاسلحه الثقيله مما ادى الى
ثقبه في القائد المركزي وصهاريج المياه
الرئيسيه والمخصصه لمرضى غسيل الكلى كما
ان هنالك عدد كبير من المستشفيات مهدد
بالخروج عن الخدمه نتيجه لشح
الوقود المطالب الاكثر الحاحا هي الالتزام
بالهدنه والعمل على الوقف الدائم لاطلاق
النار وقف هذه الحرب العبطيه
كما نطالب بفتح مسارات امنه وتحديدها
وتامينها من قبل هذه القوات المتقاتله
[موسيقى]
لا يتسع المكان هنا مستشفيات تكاد تفيض
بالمرضى وان فاضت فلا مستلزمات فيها ربما
ولا حتى اكسجين
مستشفيات تحت القصف قصف بالتوقيت الحرج لم
يتمكن مرضى الكلى من اتمام جلسه غسل طارئه
لكن ما ترى ايضا لم يكن في الحسبان
ملاذ غير امن بعد قصف العديد من
المستشفيات وتوقف بعضها عن الخدمه هذا
مستشفى ابن سينا لا شيء غير النار تعرض
للدمار بعد سقوط قداءف عشوائيه عليه
وهذا مشفى اخر سمي باسم الشعب ولم يسلم من
قذائف العسكر تدمر بالكامل يعتبر من اكبر
مستشفيات الخرطوم واكثرها حيويه
ثمت مراكز طبيه عده لكنها تعاني من نقص
المستلزمات والكوادر ايضا امر اثار قلقا
دوريا فضلا عن قلق السودانيين راح نشهد
اكيد انقطاع مش بس بمواد طبيه ولكن عدم
تسيير المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف
الشيء اللي راح نواجهه
قريبا وهذا الشيء منه ابدا ايجابي بالعكس
لازم نتدخل بسرعه لما تتفاقم الاوضاع اكثر
واكثر
دعوات حقوقيه لوقف اطلاق النار لفتح
مسارات امنه لنقل المساعدات الانسانيه
للمدنيين وان تحققت لفتره فثمت تحولات
عسكريه بين حين واخر قد تجعل الحاله اكثر
ضبابيه
غذاء السالم العربيه
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم الصحفي والمحلل
السياسي حافظ كبير اهلا بك استاذ حافظ
معنا يعني بحكم موجوده في الخرطوم كيف
تبدو الاوضاع بعد يعني اشتباكات عنيفه
حصلت في فترات الصباح هل هدات بعض الشيء
اما زالت على نفس الوتيره
[موسيقى]
لم تبدا حتى تنتهي بعد ساعه او حتى بعد
عده دقائق ما الفائده من هدى او هدنات من
هذا النوع اذا لم يلتزم فيها احد الاطراف
او كليهما
الوضع جدا ان هناك يعني الذين اقروا
الهدنه كانوا يريدون يعني الوقت او كانوا
يتعاملون معها بمنطقه وليس وليس
التزاما بها ولا يريدون الالتزاما بالهدنه
بل اقراها جاء يعني نتيجه للحديث حول
تعزيزات قادمه للخرطوم وكذلك
يعني كشف
تمركزات الطرف الاخر وبالتالي ليس من اجل
الاهداف الانسانيه التي قررتها بالتالي
يعني هذا يشكك في نوايا الذين اقرروا
الهدنه كان الاحرى بهم الالتزام بالهدنه
حتى يعني تثنى
الطواقم الطبيه وكذلك للفرق التي تريد
مساعده الناس اماكن الامر بالنسبه لهذه
الهدنه لانه قوه الجيش او الجيش السوداني
يتم قوات الدعم السريع بخرقها
ويحمله المسئوليه
محاوله ايجاد الحقيقه في اوضاعك هذه صعبه
للغايه لكن يعني نحن تابعنا ساعه الذي
دخلت فيه الهن هو يعني وقت الافطار في هذا
الوقت تحلق الطائرات في في سماء الخرطوم
وقصفت بعض الاماكن انا لا اعتقد ان القوات
الدعم السريه تمتلك الطائرات الطرف الذي
يمتلك الطائرات هو القوات
هو الجيش يعني قوات الجيش هي التي بادرت
بخلق الهدنه ام ماذا
انا اقول من الجهه التي انا فيها والمكان
الذي اسكن فيه الساعه السادسه واربع دقائق
كان هناك طائرات تحلق فوق رؤوسنا وقصفت
هذا ما استطيع تاكيده لا اعرف ما الذي حدث
في الجانب الاخر لكن هذا تاكيده هناك بيان
صدر من الدعم السريع قال بان القوات
المسلحه انتهكت
الهدنه هذا انا لا اتوقع ان الطائرات يمكن
ان تقلع في اقل من ربع ساعه حتى تصل الى
مكان الى هذا وبالتالي هناك نيه مبيته
بعدم الالتزام بالهدنه هناك مؤشر اخر ايضا
ان هناك مجموعات واسعه تؤيد الترفض الهدنه
وترى بانها اعطاء مساحه
لدعم الخارجي وما الى ذلك وبالتالي هي
تؤيد المؤسسه العسكريه للجيش وترى بانه لا
يتساهل ولا يجب ان يعطي هدنه ولا يجب ان
يسبح بتفاوض وينبغي عليه حسم الامر عسكريا
هذا امر يصعب تحقيقه في وقت وجيز او في
وقت يعني في الوقت المنظر ويكلف تكاليف
ظاهره ظللنا ندعو الى ان الحلول الصفريه
والحلول العسكريه في وسط المدن باهظه
ومكلفه ينبغي البحث عن حلول اخرى وهي
متاحه من خلال المناسبات والوسطى هناك
جهالات تريد للحلول السلميه تريد المضي
بهذا الاتجاه اتجاه الحرب للقضاء على
الطرف الاخر هذا ما يعرف
يعني كل مباراه فكريه التي لا تقبل الحلول
الوسط ولا تقبل
الخروج
بمنتصر ومنتصر وبالتالي
تدخل هذه المعرفه برغبه جانحه في الانتصار
الكافح والفناء والفناء الطرف الاخر هذا
امر غير ممكن وغير جيد ايضا لبلادنا يعقد
المشهد اكثر اتباعيا وسياسيا اقتصاديا
وامنيا ويخلق حاله جديده قد قد يعني تكون
تفوق الحاله التي حاليا من التعقيد هناك
ايضا رغبه وتاييد للحرب من اطراف ورفض
ادانا للحرب من اطراف الوافعه القوى
المدنيه والاحزاب الشخصيات المعتبره
النقابات المقاومه عدد من الفاعلين يرفضون
الحرب ويدعون الى وقفها فورا والاتجاه نحو
السلام هناك طيف اخرى تؤيد الحرب بشكل
يدعوا
للاستغراب والدهشه وهم ليسوا مقاتلين
وليسوا اعضاء في القوات المسلحه واغلب
هؤلاء من النظام البارد اعضاء الحزب
المحلول يرون في ان اي تهاون او اي حلول
وسطه تعني عوده المجموعه الاخرى وتعني
هزيمه للجيش ويصورون الامر وكانها معرفه
الكرامه الوطنيه وانها نهايه
الجاهزه واضح لاي حدود اخرى وهذا خطا يعني
نحن في السودان شهيدنا كثير من النزاعات
المسلحه انتهت انتهت
وبالتالي ليس هناك نزاع مسلح في السودان
انتهى بفناء الطرف الاخر واعتقد صوت العقل
مطلوب في هذه اللحظه النظر لتاريخ السودان
الطويل من الحروبات والنزاعات ايضا مطلوب
النظر ايضا
لما ابعد من اللحظه الراهده بعيدا عن
المصالح الحزبيه الضيقه لمصالح البلاد
واستقراره وامنها هذا ايضا امر مهم جدا
للغايه تقع عن المسؤوليه اكبر على المؤسسه
التي يعني
تدير زمام الامور حاليا يعني مثلا نحن
نقول او القوات المسلحه تقول بانها من
تتولى زمام الامور وانها المسؤوله مستورين
هي من الناحيه الاخلاقيه الى اذا افترضت
ان هناك حسب روايتها من قبل الدعم السريع
عليها
حسب
الاعراف وحسب المسؤوليات الواقعه على
عاتقها ينبغي ان لا تعرض حياه المدنيين
لهذه المخاطر الكبيره وان تخوض حربا داخل
المدن وبالتالي تقع مسؤوليات كبيره احيانا
الحلول السياسيه والتدابير العقلانيه من
اجل حياه الناس هي انتصار في حد ذاتها وهي
ايضا مسؤوليه يطلع بها الذين ينظرون الى
مصالح العليا وينظرون الى المصالح الوطن
والمواطن للذين يعني يغرقون في الخصومات
ويتمسكون بموقفهم ويعني يرغبون في التشفي
والنصر والانتصار للذات والانتصار للاجند
الضيقه هذا لا يفيد البلاد في اي شيء نحن
الان امام وضع معقد المؤسسات التي تتقاتل
الان هي كانت جزءا من بعضها البعض كما
تابعنا هناك عدد كبير من ضباط القوات
المسلحه كانوا منتدبون في القوات الدعم
السريع هذا يعني ان هناك يعني تفاهم
وتداخل وتشابه في المهام وفي العمل وفي
القوانين يعني لم ينهى انتدابهم الا بعد
ان قامت الاشتباكات وبالتالي هذا يشير الى
انهم حتى الساعه
الاخيره كانوا يعملون مع بعض طيب شكرا
جزيلا لك الصحفي والمحلل السياسي حافظ
كبير كان معنا من الخرطوم ومشاهدينا قبل
ان نكمل دعونا نلقي هذه النظره على
العلاقه المتشابكه التي جمعت قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان
فما تشاركه البرهان ودجلو على مدى السنوات
الماضيه افسدته رصاصه خرجت منذ خمسه ايام
لتتحول بعدها البلاد الى ساحه حرب يديرها
من كان يعد بحمايتها وحليفه عدو اليوم
جبهه حرب جديده فتحت افواه السلاح في
السودان طرفها الحرب عسكريان كلاهما تمرس
في ميادين القتال بدارفور اما وصفه الصداع
فمكوناتها تقتصر على وجود قوتين مسلحتين
داخل الدوله الواحده
مصير البلاد حاليا بات على راحتي من كانا
من المفترض حمايته والقادم لا ينذر الا
بصيف حار سيثقل كاهل السودانيين مجددا بعد
ان عاشوا حروبا وانقلابات عده جلبت
الويلات لهم
تاريخيا المره الاخيره التي تقاتل فيها
قائد عسكري ونائبه شرقي افريقيا كان في
جنوب السودان وقتل حينها حوالي 400 الف
شخص اما صراع اليوم فيزعزع استقرار جارتها
الشماليه وما يدور حاليا فيه قد ينتهي فقط
بفوز احدهم في المعركه مع عدم استبعاد حرب
اهليه طويله الامد قد تجر جيرانها وفق
صحيفه
على مدى السنوات الماضيه تشارك البرهان
واحمدت معارك عده معا يد واحده وقوه
مشتركه
ففي عام 2021 اكد احمدتي لصحيفه فينانشي
ان قوات الدعم السريع تدعم القوات المسلحه
السودانيه فيما اخبر البرهان الصحيفه
الغربيه انه بمجرد اكمال الانتقال الى
الديمقراطيه سيعود القاده الى التكنات
وسيتم اجراء تصويت في عام 2023
وعود تبخرت مع اطلاق رصاصه الاولى منذ
اربعه ايام من العاصمه الخرطوم ليدخل
السودان ازمه خطيره ربما يمكن ان تحسم
صلحا او تتوسع وتاكل ما تبقى من البلاد
اياد حمود العربيه
معنا الان مشاهدينا من الخرطوم الكاتب
الصحفي السوداني عادل سيد اهلا بك يا عادل
استاذ عادل معنا استاذ عادل يعني تطورات
ميدانيه كبيره تحدثنا فيها ونتحدث ايضا في
سياق هذه التغطيه ولكن مده ابدا معك
بالوضع الانساني للمواطنين السودانيين في
ظل هذا المشهد المعقد والعنيف وفي اخر
ايام من هذا الشهر الفضيل
طيب الامور لا يمكن ان نفصلها من بعضها
البعض الجانب الانساني هو انعكاس للجانب
العسكري انا اخدم في منطقه الخرطوم جنوب
وهي منطقه واقعه بين
سلاح المدرعات وهو وحده كبيره جدا تتبعات
المسلحه ومن الناحيه الجنوبيه الشرقيه
كانت تدور عمليات كبيره حيث ان هناك تواجد
لمعسكرات او وحدات تتبع للدعم السريع ولكن
الملاحظه التي اود ان اعكسها لك ان
المنطقه التي تقع غرب
او غرب الخرطوم جنوب المنطقه التي نسكنها
نحن وهي فيها سلاح المدرعات
واضح انه لا لا لم نعد نسمع اصوات
انفجارات او التيارات او ضرب رصاص حيث ان
فيما يبدو ان هذه المنطقه لم يعد فيها
وجود للدعم السريع على الرغم من انه كان
للدعم السريع والاحداث كبيره وهناك منازل
تتبع
لغاده الدعم السريع في منطقه جبره ولكن
لان سلاح المدرعات هو في مواجهه هذه
المنطقه ويبدو ان الصفوت الانفارات
والرصاص يبدو انه
انعكاس مباشر لان المعارك قد خفت كثيرا في
هذه المنطقه
وكذلك الحال في الناحيه
الشرقيه وهي منطقه سوما والتي كانت تدور
فيها معارك ضائع ضاريه ايضا كنا ن اصوات
الخيارات ضخمه جدا الان
اصبحت خافته لدرجه عاليه بالنسبه للشقه
الانساني فهذه التطورات التي ذكرتها لك
على الارض انعكست على الجانب
الانساني حيث
وجود تحركات نسبيه للمواطنين
لقضاء بعض الحاجات وكانت في البغالات او
في بعض المراكز الصحيه القريبه جدا من من
المنازل هناك تحركات شيبسي عاديه لا اقول
بشكل كامل ولكنها باينه في الشارع اطفال
يلعبون في الشارع ايضا
بالذات امس ليلا بعد اعلان الهدى استرت
راحه عند الناس بانه دي فرصه
للتحرك وبالفعل بدا الناس يتحرك وايضا
الملم جدا نحن على مسافه قريبه جدا من
الميناء البري والميناء البري هو المحطه
محطه الكبيره التي يستخدمها اهلنا الذين
يذهبون الى قضاء العيد مع اهلهم في
الولايات واضح ان هناك حركه ما في الميناء
البري تشير الى ان هناك محاولات
لترحيل من يرغب كي يذهب الى اهله في
الولايات
ويحضر معهم ايام العيد هذه طبيعه عند
السودانيين ولو ان المساله لا زالت محفوظه
بالمخاطر ولكن هناك محاولات من بعض
المواطنين ان يصلوا الى الميناء البري ثم
يتجهوا الاهلي في في القليل هذا يمكن
هذه الصوره مبسطه للوضع في جنوب الخرطوم
كما نراه وكما نسمع من خلال عمليات
العسكريه طيب ابقى معنا استاذ عادل معنا
الان مشاهدينا ايضا من القاهره السفير
حمدي صالح مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصري
الاسبق
اذا اهلا وسهلا بك سيدي معنا ودت ان اسالك
عن تقييمك لهذا المشهد والى اين ستؤول
الامور في ظل يعني حتى اي هدنه تم الاتفاق
عليها ليس فقط لم تصمت بل لم تبدا كما
راينا
يعني هناك احساس عميق لدى الراي العام
المصري ولذا الحكومه المصريه بان المعاناه
التي يعانيها الشعب السوداني يجب ان تتوقف
وهناك تعاطف عميق ما بين في الراي العام
المصري تجاه الشعب السوداني ومعانته وما
اليه وتمثل السودان ومصر شعب واحد تقريبا
وهناك اربعه مليون السوداني يعيشون في مصر
حاليا وان نتوقع ان يكون هناك زياده فيها
في العدد بعد فيما بعد وبالتالي هناك
اهتمام بالغ من الجانب المصري من جانب
الحكومه المصريه ان تتحرك للمساعده في
ايجاد حل لهذه المشكله ويبدا هذا بوقف
اطلاق النار والنظر ان احنا تفهمنا ان
الموقف الحالي لم يساعد على تثبيت الهدنه
التي دعت اليها للاطراف الدوليه خصوص
الولايات المتحده لان هناك يعني تاكل في
الثقه بشكل غير عادي بين الطرفين واحساس
لدى كل الطرف بانه يستطيع ان يمضي الى
نقطه يستطيع ان يحق فيها اهدافه وبالتالي
الجانب المصري وحاول في اتصالاته مع
الجانب
الفلسطينيه وفي اتصالهم مع الاطراف
الاقليميه والدوليه ان يغير من هذه
العقليه وان يحرك الامور نحو ان يكون هناك
توافق على هدنه انسانيه ثم هدنه حقيقيه
للوصول الى حل
ايضا هناك قضيه محوريه تواجه مصري الضمان
طبعا ضمان الامن الشعبي السوداني ولكن
ايضا ضمان المواطنين المصريين الذين
يعيشون في السودان الذين يعملون في الري
ويعملون في التدريس
ما هي الخطوات المصريه لتامين هؤلاء
يعني لم تبدا بعد يعني لهناك مشاكل عديده
في هذا الموضوع لان جميع المطارات وليس
هناك امكانيه للتحريك ولكن هناك خطط
موضوعه للتحل لتحريك هذا ونعلم ان معظم
الدول الاخرى بما فيها المانيا مثلا تتحرك
لتواضع خطه لاغلاق الرعايه الالمانيه
مصر تضع خطه لهذا في حاله ان تهدا الامور
ولكن الهمها الاول ان يكون هناك اقرار
للهدنه والوقف اطلاق النار من اجل ان يكون
هناك حد يعني وضع حد ادنى من الحياه
الانسانيه للشعب السوداني وللمواطنين غير
السودانيين اللي عايشين في السودان
المشكله ان هناك تناقضات خطيره داخل
السودان بين القوتين دول ثم ايضا بين
القوه المدنيه والقوه الاخرى ونغشى ان
تتفاقم بفعل التدخلات الاجنبيه تحدث
الكثيرون عن ان هناك التدخلات حقيقيه سواء
بالتمويل او بالذخيره او مائليه تاتي من
الخارج ثم ستتزايد القوه الغربيه لها دور
وايضا القوه الاقليميه سواء ما لا اريد ان
اسميها وبالتالي عدم عدم يعني الخط المصري
يتطلب ان لا يكون هناك تدخل اجنبيا في
السودان
لا نسمح بتحول السودان ولا يجب ان يسمع
المجتمع الدولي بالتحويل السودان الى
مشكله اخرى زي مشكله ليبيا واليمن
والسوريه حيث تتفاقم الامور وتستمر لفترات
طويله نحن نامل ان يكون هناك تحركا سريعا
ولذلك مصر تقدمت بمبادرتين المبادره
الاخيره فيها نقاط محدده دقيقه لتحقيق
للتحرك نحو
وقف اطلاق النار ثم تضع افق امام الطرفين
بحيث انهم فقط ليس هناك وقف اطلاق نار
ايضا افق للمفاوضات للوصول الى ما يريدونه
في حد لحد ادنى من مصالحهم وايضا
المصريه تحاول ان تقدم نظام
لتثبيت وقفه اطلاق النار عن طريق مراقبين
دوليين بالتعاون المتحده والتعاون القوى
الدوليه الاساسيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
والاتحاد الافريقي وبالتالي هناك على
الاقل مبادره مصريه بخطوط وبخطوات تنفيذيه
وايضا بخطوات سياسيه بتتعلق بانه يجب ان
يكون هناك ادراك لان المصالح الطرفين
مرتبطين بمصالح الشعب السوداني ككل وايضا
ابعاد خطر التدخلات الاجنبيه وده خطر
حقيقي وماسل امامنا ان هناك من يتحدث عن
طائرات تنزل في مروه وتقدم من الزخير لهذا
الطرف واخرين يتحدثون عن تدخل اخر يعني ده
خطر خطير سيؤثر على مستقبل السودان بشكل
عام
نسمح بهذا ولكن المجتمع الدولي ارجو ان
تبقى معنا ساعود لك بعد قليل مشاهدينا في
الاخبار العاجله التي تاتينا الان اعلام
سودانيه يقول ان السلطات الامنيه قطعت
الاتصالات عن قاده الدعم السريع بمن فيهم
حميدتي اذا اعلام سوداني يتحدث عن ان
السلطات الامنيه قطعت الاتصالات عن قاده
الدعم السريع بمن فيهم حمايتي
ونحن الان مشاهدينا سنذهب لنتعرف على ابرز
سيناريوهات التي قد ترسم مستقبل السودان
مع استمرار المواجهات والتصعيد بين طرفي
الصراع خصوصا وان الهدنه المعلنه لم تنجح
بالاساس كما اشرنا
الطاوله التي جلسا الى جهه واحده منها
للسنوات انقلبت والوساطه باتت مطلوبه لوعد
المواجهه المسلحه بينهما في مهد العاصمه
بعد اربعه ايام على انزلاق رجلي الحكم
العسكري في السودان الى مستنقع القتال
سيناريوهات ثلاثه محتمله رسمت لمستقبل
المواجهه بين قائد القوات المسلحه ونائبه
السيناريو الاول ذهب الى حرب شوارع طويله
تنحصر في العاصمه مع محاوله كل طرف فيها
حسم المعركه لمصلحته لكنه ينتهي بانتشار
قوات الجيش السوداني في كافه المناطق
والاحياء فاعتماد الجيش استراتيجيه
استنزاف الموارد وتفوقه من ناحيه المعدات
العسكريه والطائرات قد يكون نقطه الفصل
على ارض المعركه حيث ستفقد قوات الدعم
السريع ذات التسليح الخفيف والمتوسط مؤنها
من وقود وذخيره وغذاء خلال ثلاثه ايام من
الاشتباك المتواصل اول السيناريوهات رجح
انسحاب احمدتي تكتيكيا الى دارفور في حال
حوصره من الجيش ليتظلل بقواته المتمرده
مجردا من اي او مشاركه بالمشهد السياسي
الا في حال التسويه اما السيناريو الثاني
فيتمثل بوقف لاطلاق النار بعد وسطات عربيه
وغربيه يليه بدء عمليه التفاوض والمحاكمات
العسكريه لينتهي بدمج قوات الدعم السريع
المتبقيه مع الجيش
بما يشمل السيناريو الثالث وقف اطلاق
النار وعوده الجميع للتسويه وهنا الاحتمال
المطروح عدم وجود قوات الدعم السريع كطرف
رئيسيا في العمليه التفاوضيه والذهاب
لفتره انتقاليه جديده تهيئ للانتخابات
نعود اذا مشاهدينا مره اخرى
للخرطوم والى الكاتب الصحفي السوداني عادل
السيد هناك استاذ عادل يعني اسالك ربما عن
موضوع التقرير الذي استمعنا وراء شاهدناه
قبل قليل ماذا برايك هي سيناريوهات
المستقبل الان بعد هذه المشاهد التي نراها
بالنسبه للسودان
قبل نعم قبل ذلك هناك نقطه هامه جدا اود
ان اشير اليها
وصلتني قبل قليل عبر اتصالات
بالموبايل انه لا بد من ايجاد ممرات
انسانيه لان الاوضاع الصحيه واوضاع
المصابين يعني
اصبحت اقرب للكارثه ولذلك نحن نناسب اطراف
الصراع ونناشد الامم المتحده وخلاف
والمنظمات العامله بان تتحرك بهذا لان
المواطن ما عاد يستطيع ان يصل المستشفيات
بالشكل المطلوب هذه الملاحظه عامه وجدت ان
اشير اليهم فيما يتعلق
ثم ماذا بعد انا اعتقد انه
المعارك التي تدور الان واضح انها ستخلق
وضع جديد للتفاوض وستخلي رؤيه جديده
من المهم جدا ان نقول
تصريحات غاده الجيش قبل ايام بانهم
ملتزمون
بالمسار السياسي انا اعتقد هذه النقطه
هامه جدا لانه الان هناك شكوك كثير جدا
لدى الكثيرين ان هذه المعارك المستفيد
يستفيد منها بشكل كبير الفنون فنون النظام
السابق اذا هناك بدايه الازمه حديث عن
انه فلول النظام السابق هي من زرعت بذور
الفتنه ما بين شقي المكون العسكري وادت
الى ما نراه الان لا ادري اذا كنت تتفق
اصلا مع هذه النظريه
نعم اصلا اصلا فلول النظام السابق على اقل
تقدير هم يقومون بما ان نسميه نحن المدينه
حركتني المدينه حركته تعني انه اذا كان
هناك
طرفان
مثلا بينهما مشكله او خلاف فان هناك طرف
ثالث يحاول ان يزكل المعركه بين الطرفين
انا اقول في اقل التقديرات او باقل
التقديرات الفنون يعني مستفيدين جدا من
هذه الحرب
ولهم مصلحه حقيقيه في استمرارها لان وقف
الحرب يعني العوده لطاوله المفاوضات يعني
الالتزام بمدنيه الدوله يعني بتحقيق مطالب
الثوره وهذا كله يتعارض ويتضارب مع مصلحه
الفنون ولكن قاده الجيش الان يؤكدون انهم
مصممون على السير
نعم استاذ عادل يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال
مشاهدينا مع عادل السيد الكاتب الصحفي
السوداني سنحاول اعاده الاتصال به اذا
تسنى لنا ذلك
دعونا لان نلقي نظره اخرى على معاناه
المدنيين جراء هذه المواجهات المستمره حيث
سقط الكثير من الضحايا من بينهم طبيبه
شابه هي ابنه كابتن الهلال ومدربها السابق
فوزي المرضي بينما اصيبت والدتها جراء
رصاصه طائشه اصابت نافذه منزلهم في
اندرمان
بالعربيه
وصلت البيت مبسوطه جدا مرتاحه يعطيني في
الوضع
فنجان قهوه لان انا انا فاطر
جدا لما طلعت من الاوضه الصغيره في
الصالون به هناك
مشهد امها قالت لها هنا قالوا
الشباك
مختلفه القزاز
كنت
طلقه طوالي كسره القزاز ضربت امها في
الاول في الفقه الايمن حقها شعره اللحم
بتاع الفجر ضرباتها في بتاعتها ومشط ضربت
البنت في قلبها
مباشره وقعت
متوفيه توفى الطوال في الحال
لم يسلم الاطفال من الاشتباكات حيث قتلت
طفل جراء سقوط مقذوفا على مجموعه اطفال
كانوا يلعبون تحت ظلال شجره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا وقد تمكنت قوات الجيش من اجلاء عدد من
طلاب وموظفي جامعه الخرطوم كانوا عالقين
داخل الجامعه على مدى اربعه ايام
اخلاء العالمين بجامعه
بالراحه كده
جامعه الخرطوم
اربعه يوم واحد واحد
دام القتال ليوم الخامس على التوالي
المتابعه
احداث متسارعه يشهدها السودان في رابع
ايام الاشتباكات الداميه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع لكن الرؤيه النهائيه بشان
الطرف العسكري الذي سيبسط سيطرته على
الارض لم تتضح حتى هذه اللحظه تعددت
الروايات بين الاطراف المتنازعه والمتضرر
واحد الشعب السوداني الذي عانى وما زال من
هذه الصراعات معدلات القتل والاصابات
تتزايد بوتيره متفاقمه والعديد من
المستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه فبعضها ضربت
بالقذائف والبعض الاخر انقطعت عنه
الكهرباء ولا يجد للامدادات الطبيه سبيله
اذا استمر القتال سيكون هناك المزيد من
الضحايا الارقام التي حصلت عليها لم يتم
تاكيدها نحن نعتمد على معلومات من الاطباء
السودانيين ومن المستشفيات حتى الان قتل
ما لا يقل عن 185 شخصا واصيب من 1800 شخص
بمن فيهم مدنيون وعناصر الجيش تحرك صعب
يواجه السكان في ظل القصف الجوي
والاشتباكات العنيفه على الارض
واماكن متفرقه احتجز فيها السودانيون منذ
بدايه الاشتباكات ومنها الجامعات غير
المجهزه لحال كهذه والعديد من هؤلاء
المحتجزين حاولوا الخروج للعوده الى
منازلهم اثناء هدنه وقف اطلاق النار التي
دعت اليها بعثه الامم المتحده الا ان
الاطراف المتصارعه لم تلتزم بها رغم
التعهدات باحترامها
احنا حوالي 88
نفر مننا عشرين عامل فيهم كبار السن
وفي حوالي خمسه طالبات المعارك في السودان
احدثت نكسه غذائيه بسبب صعوبه التنقل
وارتفاع الاسعار وسط تعليق العشرات من
برامج المساعدات الانسانيه بعد ان نهبت
الامدادات ودمرت المس
لا يمكنني اعطائك اي ارقام محدده حول قيمه
الممتلكات المسروقه او الامدادات المنهوبه
او حتى المساعدات التي دمرت بسبب القتال
كما قلت في وقت سابق في هذه الظروف لا
يمكن ان يحدث اي توصيل للمساعدات بشكل
اساسي تمديد وقلق اماميان واطراف اقليميه
ودوليه تقف على خط الازمه التي اتساحه
الثالثه اكبر بلد افريقي الا ان تلك
المساعي والمحاولات المتعدده لم تجد اذانا
صاغيه حتى الان
سلطان العيبان العربيه
ومشاهدينا ما زلنا اذا مع هذه الصور الحيه
والمباشره من الخرطوم استمرار الاشتباكات
في محيط القياده العامه ومناطق متفرقه في
الخرطوم نحن نرى الان ارتفاع اعمده الدخان
غير الكثيف على ما يبدو من بعض المناطق
كان هناك اشتباكات عنيفه منذ صباح اليوم
ولكنها على ما يبدو هدات نوعا ما الجيش
اسود السوداني يقول بانه يواصل عملياته ضد
الدعم السريع بشكل متقدم
واحترافي
وطبعا ما زلنا مشاهدينا مع صور حيه تاتينا
من الخرطوم في هذه التغطيه
المفتوحه والمستمره لاحداث السودان في ضمن
الاخبار العاجله التي تاتينا الان الجيش
السوداني يقول وتيره القتال ضد دعم السريع
بطيئه لمراعاه سلامه المدنيين
الان معنا من الخرطوم الدكتور عطيه عبد
الله عطيه سكرتير نقابه الاطباء السودانيه
اهلا بك دكتور عطيه معنا دكتور نريد ان
نفهم الوضع الطبي في السودان مع ارتفاع
اعداد الاصابات واعداد اعداد القتلى ونقص
يعني اساسيات التشغيل في كثير من
المستشفيات هذا ناهيك عن ربما تعرضها
لاطلاق النار ايضا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
وخالص التعازي لجماهير الشعب السودانيات
الصحه والعافيه لكل الجرحى والمصابين
وعوده حميدا لكل المفقودين نعم كما ذكرتي
الوضع الانساني سيء للغايه في السودان
عموما وعلى وجه الخصوص ولاده الخرطوم عدد
من المستشفيات
اؤكد لك ان 39 مستشفى مستشفى كبير قدر
نعول عليهم كثيرا توقف تماما جزء منهم
داخل الخرطوم وجزء خارج الخرطوم ايضا
نقص الامدادات الطبيه والمعينات وكذلك
الغذاءات يشكل هاجس كبير تم اخلاء عدد من
المستشفيات في من قلب الخرطوم لانعدام
الامن فيها لذلك نحن نجدد طلبا لطرفي
الصراع لوقت هذه الحرب العباسيه فورا وفتح
مجالات ومسارات امنه لخروج الجرحى
والمصابين وتوصيل المعينات الانسانيه
للمستشفيات
وصلتنا عدد من التاكيدات من عدد من اصدقاء
السودان في عدد من المنظمات ولكن هم
يطالبون بفتح ممرات امنه حتى يتمكنوا
بالوصول الى هذه المستشفيات وتقديم الدعم
المطلوب
كذلك نشاهد ونتابع عمليات نزوح كبيره من
الخرطوم هنا
ونؤكد ونجدد طلبا لطرفه الصراع بعدم
الممات
بالمواطنين وعدم تعريض حياتهم للخطر وعدم
تعرضهم لاي عنف في طريقهم الى اهاليهم في
الولايات ما تابعناه وما راجع عن معلومات
خطيره نرجو ان لا تتكرروا ايضا محافظه على
ارواحهم كذلك نطالب بتامين الكوادر الطبيه
وفتح مسارات امنه لها للاسف الشديد ودت ان
اسالك عن هذا الموضوع تحديدا ما هي يعني
هل تجدون صعوبه في الوصول
يعني المتضررين سواء كانوا
اصابات ام قتله
ليس لدينا امكانيه للوصول اليها لانه لم
يتوقف اطلاق النار منذ اليوم الاول نحن
نحاول ان نستعين بكوادرنا الطبيه الاقرب
لاي مستشفى جزء من الكوادر الطبيه لم يتم
تغييرها منذ صبيحه السبت الماضي
اصوات الرصاص في كل مكان يعني
هنا نحذر الطرفي الصراع بعدم استخدام
المسخفيات والمنشات الطبيه لاي منطلق
لعملاتهم العسكريه وعدم وضع اي الغام اذا
عدنا الى هذه المستشفيات نحذرهم تحذير
اولي ونهايه هذه الحرب يجب ان تتوقف فورا
ايضا هنالك عدد من المرضى من كبار السن
وذوي الامراض المزمنه يحتاج الى الذهاب
الى الصيدليات الصيدليات مغلقه تماما ولكن
الوضع الامني ايضا هو غير غير مطمن لذلك
نحن نطلب من كل الكوادر الطبيه والصيدليات
التواجد او فتح هذه الصيدلات اذا اذا كان
هنالك او اذا سمح الوضع الامني في في
الخرطوم بقيه الولايات طيب يعني دكتور هل
يعني وضع بنفس السوء في كافه المناطق
السودانيه وكافه مناطق الخرطوم ام انه
هناك يعني الاماكن التي تتركز فيها
الاشتباكات وتبادل اطلاق النار تعاني اكثر
يعني فيما يتعلق بالقطاع الطبي من غيرها
نعم هي قد حددنا اكثر من ثمانيه ولايات من
مود من 18 ولايه بالسودان هي الان فيها
عمليات عسكريه ولكن يتفاوت الوضع من ولايه
الى اخرى وايضا من منطقه الى اخرى ولكن
هذا هدوء هذه في بعض المناطق لان يعني
نتوقع ان تمتد العمليات العسكريه من
الخرطوم الى او من الولايات الاخرى لذلك
نحن ارسلنا نداء لكل قواديننا الطبيه في
عموم السودان
يعني يكونوا على اهبه الاستعداد وانتظار
التحديثات من طرفنا اذا كانت هنالك
اي هدنه او مسارات امنه حتى نمكنهم
بالوصول الى هذه المستشفيات وتقديم الدعم
الطبي نحن نتحدث عن الجرحى والمصابين ولكن
هنالك شريحه اكبر
من المرضى المنومين في المستشفيات بالامس
تم اجراء مستشفى الخرطوم مستشفى جعفر بن
عوف وايضا قبل قليل انقطع الاكسجين في
مستشفى شرق النيل هذا الوضع خطير للغايه
وينبئ بكوارث طبيه كذلك يعني المرضى
الموجودين في المنازل المرضى المنومين
يعني الاعداد المستشفيات العامله تتناقص
اما لعدم امكانياتها الاستقبال الجرحى او
لانعدام الكوادر الطبيه وذلك بسبب انعدام
الامن وعدم امكانيه الوصول الى هذه
المستشفيات
القاهره مشاهدينا والى
سياده السفير
هل مازال الباب مفتوحا لجهود وساطه عربيه
مصريه تحديدا
او افريقيه لايجاد حل لهذه الازمه ومنع
تفاقمها ام انه يعني مع تعنت الطرفين
وازدياد المشهد عنفا واشتعالا كما نرى هذا
الباب اصبح مقفولا الان
لا لم يعد الباب ما مقلقا ولكن المشكله
انه ما زال هناك تصلب في موقف الطرفين
لان كلا الطرفين وخصوصا الدعم السريع
يتصور انها ان ما زال امامه فرصه للتحقيق
اهدافه بالطريق العسكريه
نحن يعني تفهمي للتحرك المصري ولتحرك
العربي ان احنا بنحشد ضغوط عربيه واقليبيه
ودوليه على الطرفين لكي يقبلوا فورا بوقف
اطلاق النار ولوضع خطه للتحرك في المستقبل
وبالتالي النقطه الاساسيه لوقف اطلاق
النار هو ان يكون هناك مراقبين ليس فقط في
وقفه مراقبين لايقاف هو لتثبيته وايضا
نامل ان تقوم الامم المتحده وتنظمته
المنظماتها المختلفه بوضع خطه للتحرك
الفوري لمساعده السودان في وضعه الكارثي
الصحي
والاجتماعيليه لان دي قضيه محوريه تواجه
العالم ككل ولا يمكن ان نترك هذه الماساه
تمر بهذا الشكل ان تصوري ان
هيئات الامم المتحده تستطيع ان تقدم الان
خطه للتحرك بتقديم المساعدات طبعا مشكله
خطيره هي ان جميع المرافق مغلقه وخصوصا
المطارات ولكن يمكن تقديمها عن طريق البري
عن طريق بورسودان وتحرك القوافل طبيه من
بورسودان الى في ممرات امنه الى الخرطوم
للمساعده نامل ان تتحرك القوه الاقليميه
والقوه والمنظمات الدوليه في هذا الخط
وايضا نامل ان يكون هناك نظره للجميع
وخصوصا القاده المتصارعين الى ما بعد
اللحظه الراهنه اللحظه الراهنه هي صراعات
وهي صناعه عنيفه صدام عنيفه وتؤثر تاثيرا
خطيرا على السودان لانه تدمير ذاتي
للسودان وبدافع من مدافع شخصيه ودوافع
سياسيه ودوافع ايضا من قوه اجنبيه ولكن
نامل ان يكون هناك نظرا لما بعد
اللحظه الراهنه ماذا سيحدث للسودان يجب ان
يكون هناك نظره مستقبليه ومصر تامل ان
تكون شريكا في المساعده في اعاده
الاستقرار والامن الى السودان واعاده
البناء لمساعده في تخفيف المعاناه على
الشعب السوداني انا اعتقد يعني الموقف
الحالي موقف خطير يجب ان تتحرك المجتمع
الدولي ككل فعاليه اكثر وهو هذا ما تساعد
عليه المبادره المصريه المتعدده
ورغم ان الهدنه التي يعني عرضت تاكلت فورا
بعد البدايه الا انه من المامول ان ان نصل
الى خدنا في اثناء عيد الفطر مع الايام
المباركه ان هناك ايمان قوي لدى الشعب
السوداني ككل بما فيه طرفين انه لا يجب ان
يكون هناك صراع بهذا الشكل والمعاناه في
اثناء هذه الفتره التي تعتبر مقدسه من
الدين الاسلامي شكرا جزيلا لك السفير حمدي
صالح مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصريه الاسبق
معنا من القاهره اعود
بشكل مباشر مشاهدينا الى الخرطوم الى
دكتور عطيه عبد الله عطيه هل ما زال معنا
يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال به اذا مشاهدينا
معنا وما زلنا مع هذه الصور الحيه
والمباشره من الخرطوم حيث الجيش السوداني
ودعم السريع يتبادلان الاطلاق النار
والاشتباكات منذ الصباح وحتى يعني منذ
خمسه ايام ولكن كان من المفترض ان يكون
هناك هدنه تم الاتفاق عليها ل 24 ساعه
للاسف هذه الهدنه لم تبدا اصلا ولم تصمد
حتى اقل من ساعه
وبالتالي طبعا ازدادت وتيره القصف
والاشتباكات هذا الصباح كان هناك استهداف
لمطار
الخرطوم حيث تم
استهداف او
اشتعلت النيران في احد خزانات الوقود داخل
المطار ايضا في ذات الوقت كان هناك
اشتباكات عنيفه تدور حول مقر قياده الجيش
في الخرطوم
وايضا رصدنا اشتعال وارتفاع اعمده الدخان
من احد المباني في محيط هذا المقر
ايضا مشاهدينا اظهرت الصور تحليق مقاتلات
تابعه للجيش السوداني في انحاء السودان
لملاحقه تمركزات قوات الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا مع الصور الحيه
والمباشره التي تصلنا من الخرطوم لاستمرار
هذه الاشتباكات ما بين قوات الدعم السريع
وقوات الجيش السوداني الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع كان تبادلا الاتهامات بخرق
الهدنه منذ ليله امس ايضا
وكانت هناك او تم رصد ارتفاع وتيره القصف
والاشتباكات خلال فتره الصباح ومن ثم على
ما يبدو هدات بعض الشيء رغم اننا نرى يعني
ارتفاع اعمده الدخان كما ترون على يمين
الشاشه
فهذه الاشتباكات ما زالت مستمره حتى وان
كان بشكل متقطع
اذا مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه مستمره معكم اذا
على مدار الساعه لابرز التطورات وما يجري
في السودان الان نعود مره اخرى الى الرياض
والزملاء هناك الاستكمال هذه التغطيه الى
اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات